good evening and welcome to this
Northwest area planning meeting on
today's 2nd of November 2022. my name is
councilor Maddie Thompson and I'm the
chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded when invited to speak please
turn on your microphone and speak
clearly referencing a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers please keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking as this is important for the
live streaming to be heard clearly
finally can I draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind this top table
members there is no members update this
evening
that I know about anyway
so item two please miss Bird's apologies
for absence
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
so our item three members it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on 5th of October found on
pages seven to ten are approved as a
true and accurate record may I take them
as read thank you
you're racing ahead um I so propose uh
would anybody second that please
um okay I actually spotted councilor
Morgan first thank you
um any matters of accuracy for anyone to
raise
I'll take that as a no so can we accept
those by Cent members please
right item four is Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable registerable
interest relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members and members are reminded
they're also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware should the needs arise through the
meeting
right councilor key is going first
okay my insurance
interest uh gender number six double two
zero zero eight one four I went to Young
Farmers with the applicant but we've
just worked out that was 24 years ago
okay
as long as that yes I know I don't look
it
can't imagine
um
Council Fleming thanks thank you chair a
registerable as a member of Essex County
Council who our statutory consultees and
also registerable for agenda item six uh
so I will be leaving the chamber after
the first application thank you thank
you
anybody oh come from White sorry
thank you manager and just a non-pakini
interest that I know the applicant of a
gender item six because he sits on
purview Parish Council which is in my
ward thank you very much
okay so that takes us to item five which
is the first planning application land
of Willows and Stevenson Road North
fanbridge so uh there are no no public
speakers on this one so um we can have
the presentation please from standby
thank you chairman
foreign
planning permission with all matters
reserved is sought for the residential
development of the site for up to two
dwellings the outline application
procedure allows for applicants to
identify specific matters for
consideration the application has
identified that this application is to
consider the principle of development
only
should outline permission be granted for
the proposal the considerations of
layout access scale appearance and
Landscaping would form a subsequent
Reserve matters application
foreign
the site is located on the Northern side
of Stevenson road just outside of the
defined settlement boundary of North
fanbridge which is located on the edge
of the site here
the site is located at the end of a run
of Residential Properties along
Stevenson Road and the train station
serving North fanbridge is located
approximately 250 meters away from the
site here
this station is on the south Minster
Branch line from Whitford to
southminster
this is the block plan due to the
outline nature of the application
details relating to the layout access
and appearance would form a subsequent
Reserve matters application
this is the existing tree constraints
plan
these are photographs of the application
site taken from Stevenson Road
these are photographs taken from the
front of the site and looking into the
site from the existing access
this is a photograph of the David Wilson
homes development located south of the
site
and these are photographs of the
existing Bungalows and Chalet Bungalows
already located along Stevenson Road
as discussed within the committee report
the proposed development is considered
to represent sustainable development and
would assist albeit marginally in
addressing the current five-year housing
land Supply shortfall
subject to the conditions listed in
Section 8 of the report it is considered
that the application site would be able
to accommodate two dwellings in a form
that would appear in keeping with the
prevailing pattern of development within
the area and would be large enough to
provide adequate room for car parking
and private amenity space for two
dwellings The Proposal is therefore
considered to comply with the policies
within the local development plan and is
recommended for approval thank you
chairman thank you and while I'm a
remember this is in fact the standards
last Northwest with us um she's not
leaving just yet but this is her last
goal here with us
moving on thank you
uh right members um I'll open the
discussion and trust a proposal of some
sort will come out of that we've got a
recommendation for approval but I shall
put that on the table just yet so I
would like to go spot it councilor
Morgan first thanks thank you madam
chairman um I'm just sort of a bit
disappointed probably not as
disappointed as a North famish Parish
councilor that um the officers haven't
really addressed their objections as
raised in their representations
um in particular the fact that it is
outside the settlement boundary and
conflicts with policy sa it's not one of
the 13 exceptions and I'm particularly
interested about that because of what
may be coming up later on I just
wondered perhaps the officers could
perhaps expand a bit on their reasons
for not taking account of those
objections rather than just simply
saying noted
it's done good thank you yes thank you
chairman for you
um
within section
5.2 of the report relates to the
principle of development and as
discussed although the application site
is located on the periphery of the
defined settlement boundary there have
been multiple appeal decisions within
North fanbridge that have stated that
sites within the this area and further
away from the site are considered to be
sustainable so despite the fact that the
defined settlement is outside the of the
defined settlement boundary because of
those appeal decisions and because we
don't have a five-year housing land
Supply we have to consider the
accessibility and sustainability of the
site
um
which is discussed within section 5.2 of
the report so that's why that
um consideration has been made
it so it just strikes me I'm just
concerning not just this application
with others this business of the
settlement boundary just seems to be a
bit of a sort of moving Feast to be able
to be taken account of or not as the
case may be
specific to this application because I
think Miss Miss Dungey answered in
respect of uh that point on the parish's
comments but but uh well uh perhaps I
was more of a general comment perhaps
that I would be interested to see your
view as to how quite how important uh
one should take that settlement boundary
well
really I think I think Miss Miss Dungy
answered that and I think it's within
the the principal section where it
specifically talks about
the status of the settlement boundary
particularly in respect of whether one
has a five-year housing land Supply or
not and and and paragraph 11d is is it
is triggered because
particularly in the case of moldum we
don't have the five-year housing land
Supply
um the whole issue around where the
policies are considered to be out of
date or relevant or in line with
government thinking about the provision
of housing so that's really the context
of how the whole settlement boundary
issue is considered
um
if the five-year housing land is
supplied then the five then the
settlement boundary and development has
to be take taken place within the
settlement is then given precedent
because we're delivering on on on on The
Wider government objectives for
providing housing if we don't in a way
source of saying well your policies
aren't delivering in the way that it
should because you're not complying with
the stated policies I've provided the
requisite amount of development
within the five-year period in the
corners with your plan so basically your
plans failing
thank you
okay cancer wise thank you uh chairman
for letting me speak all right I've got
a few queries really
um on every other application we've had
in various different parts of the
district and I will say including one of
my own
um an understatement an unmade Road was
classed as unsustainable and therefore
it should be refused because you cannot
expect people to walk along an unmade
Road
um so that's why I'm a bit surprised
that it's under 5.2.9 you acknowledge
it's non-made Road you acknowledge that
it's not good to walk along because
there's no street lights or anything
else indeed you can see it on here so I
wondered why that applied to every other
site in the district but it doesn't
apply to this one so that's my first one
um they said the next one is under
section 5.3 which is housing mix
um you also go on to say that well this
is what we need but actually we don't
know what it's going to be
um and my concern because the outline
nature I think it's very unfair on the
other residents that they can't come
into what it is and from experience will
we get these applications come in by the
time we get the actual house plans
coming they go oh sorry you've already
approved you can't turn it down because
you'll lose an appeal so that that for
me is a problem but then the other
problem I've got is with the access if
we go back to the site
um all of the other houses have clear
access from the unmade Road
and it appears to me looking at this
plan that it's only a tiny weeny bit of
road that goes this there isn't actually
any access because there's no existing
accuracy so you're not even using the
existing Road
is it not just stuck on the end and
there's only a tiny Wii Cube so unlike
all the other houses that have got clear
driveways going off of the unmade Road
it looks to me like this has got a
driveway of a very small driveway so
both houses are going to have to be
serviced by a little tiny
um a tiny block rather than every other
house that's in the road has a proper
driveway of its own is that right or am
I wrong
okay
yeah
um through you chairman if I can come
back on the three points made so as far
as I've recorded it the initial
um comment was made about the unmade
Road and why we are recommending
approval
um for that
um so obviously without knowing the
specifics of the other sites you're
referring to they may be contextually
different in that they're not 250 meters
away from a train station which serves
other Villages and has and therefore
residents can access other services and
Facilities quite easily
um and as I've already noted in section
5.2 of the report there have been
multiple appeal decisions that have
stated that this area is sustainable
including Stevenson Road and whilst
acknowledging that they would have to
Future occupiers would have to walk
along a road that doesn't have lights
those appeal decisions are material
weight in terms of determining this
application so
it would be very it would not be
consistent to move away from the
approach already taken by multiple
inspectors about this area should we not
have the same approach district-wide if
it's deemed to be sustainable and
everything apart from the unmade Road
should we not have a consistent approach
because I know I'm going to get issues
after this one with people saying well
why was it not okay for my anime road
but anyway sorry carry on
yes Mr Johnson please thank you chairman
I mean just to add to that I think
too many microphones sorry yeah yeah
what um Miss donga is saying is that is
this is the specific circumstances of of
this application and again that's
something that we generally do say we
speak to the specific circumstances of
the application in front of us
the specific circumstances here that
there are these other these appeal
decisions within this area speaking
about the uh same sort of uh access and
and and and and and and traveling issues
the unmade road unlit but still consider
that given the distances to services and
the railway station they are considered
to be sustainable we will still continue
to be making the argument about the
unsustainability in those areas where we
don't have this sort of precedent or or
these material considerations in terms
of appeal decisions so this is peculiar
to this area here so we have to we have
to take cognizance of that we can't make
the same argument when there's three
appeal decisions basically saying the
area is sustainable thank you chairman
okay if I could also add to that
determine
um in a lot of other cases as well when
it's an unmade Road or it's a road it's
that
future occupies I occupiers would have
to walk down it's normally a road which
is the national speed limit is unsafe
and in this instance the road although I
made is a residential street which is
250 meters from the train station
right okay and uh could we go on to the
axis on the site and there's a couple
other things also I wanted to raise so
this this access here that that to me
seems very small to try and get to two
houses and I've got concerns you'll be
able to get the driveway in it's
certainly not going to match the linear
pattern of all the other houses and why
does the roadway not go all the way
along the application site like all the
other houses in the road do I mean for
me this is a a big design flaw
um can I come back on the other points
right yes the housing mix
um so the point raised about the housing
mix
um as stated within section 5.3 of the
report
um although the housing mix hasn't been
specifically stated we have recommended
a condition to say that it should be
three bedrooms only to meet the
identified need of the district
um and then coming on to a point about
access
um this road is unadopted
um there have been no highways
objections
so they have included this area within
the red line but the specific detailed
nature of access would be addressed at
the reserve matters stage
would you be able to fit a a fire engine
through there
if somebody's got cars partly because
presumably the houses would have to be
in in the same position as the house
next to them
and what I'm saying is if people had
Cars one car on each driveway would you
still be able to get a fire engine
through because that looks really narrow
obviously I don't know how many meters
it is I I just think it's just a really
poor design not to have the access going
along the front like all the other
houses do
Mr Johnson yeah thank you chairman
this is an outline application so
specifically matters of detailed design
are not for consideration
but we
if I might come back my problem is you
can't change the red line boundary at
the secondary state of the application
so if the house is presumably they would
have to be in in the same road Frontage
position as of the house next to them
so for me I I've got a problem with that
getting the access in I just think
that's a really poor red line boundary
in this they don't own the land well
looks like they do own the land but
um to get anything in and out of that
site because we have to be mindful being
being careful about what we're allowing
permission for
um
and I think that's just really strange
that you've only got one tiny little
Cube to access two houses so anyway the
highways remixes
if I can just say that um
the this this this outline application
will all matters are reserved uh means
we're only considering the principle
the subsequent Reserve matters um
applications if this application were to
be approved would be subject to the to
the usual detailed scrutiny it could
well be the case that in a reserved
matters application it fails there's
there's no guarantee that in an outline
application particularly of this nature
being granted
um that a reserve matters application
would be approved
I mean I'll probably say most outline
applications at least access may be one
of the considerations but it doesn't
have to be
and that that's the case here
yeah I'm just thank you Jim thank you
just responding the other thing is um am
I right in thinking they haven't
actually submitted uh each logical and
habitats reports that's something else I
really further through
you chairman now they have submitted
those reports
what I'm doing something what they
haven't got them okay thank you okay
thank you but I've got Council of
Fleming Council accusing Council of
siddle thank you
thank you chair
um thank you Hannah my concern with this
particular site is we recently refused
an application in Stevenson Road which I
understand was because it was sort of
backfill
um so my concern with that application
site just looking it's sort of narrower
is that uh you know if we did Grant
outline here is that they could apply
for a house at the front and a house at
the back
so and again given counselor White's
concerns about the access I'm concerned
about that as well
um so I wanted your comments on that
thank you through you chairman
um yes as you have stated
um there was an application here which
was refused and dismissed because of the
impact on the character of the area
being that it's
it's not isolated but I'm going to use
the term isolated along a road where
there's no other development and it
would constitute backplan development
behind Stevenson Stevenson Road
um obviously this area of land is
completely different it's at the end of
a residential Road and
um in terms of this being outlined in
nature we're not dealing with the
detailed design of this of the layout of
the site which would come at Reserve
matter stage and
obviously if they come in with a design
and layout that was not reflective of
the prevailing character of the area
that it's unlikely that we would support
it so
it is considered that they could come
forward with the design and layout that
would reflect the character of the area
I.E a linear fronting development not to
houses in the tandem Arrangement
um so again that would be considered at
the reserve matter stage and it's not
for consideration as part of this
application but it is considered that a
reasonable layout and design could be
achieved
thank you Hannah
um I'm also thinking about rectory Road
there was uh an application at the end
of that road I think the uh there were
two applications there and two appeals
refused uh the inspector said in his
view that the village stopped there uh
just short of it and so just looking at
I mean you can't see from that plan
if you went over the railway
so
yeah so just sort of over the railway
that site would be sort of
in close proximity so
I just have concerns about extending the
boundary in this way
thank you three german yes
um I'm familiar with that site
um I think it's very different in that
it's got agricultural buildings located
on it and has a completely different
visual appearance within the street than
this site does which is very contained
and doesn't really contribute to the uh
rural Countryside and there's also
another appeal decision that's been made
further north of the defined settlement
which was a loud appeal
um on a road that is not made and
doesn't have the same character as this
street scene so
this is considered to be not as harmful
to the character of the area as those
other applications so that's why we're
recommending approval in this instance
counselor keys
thank you madam chairman councilor watch
sold a bit of my thunder can we go back
to the pictures please
if you walk down the unmade track I know
where we are as such when you get onto
Cambridge Road isn't it famous road is
there a footpath all the way down to the
railway station
uh chairman I don't believe there there
is
on an application in
Flemings and Mrs White's or the other
month we were
modern counts were saying we couldn't
have the development because there was
no footpath
yet today we're saying we can
it's sustainable
and they because there's a station there
but you can't walk down the road because
there's no footpath
I seem to be struggling sometimes with
some of these reasons while we're
refusing them and then all of a sudden
we can pass it yet there's no foot off
and also councilor myself have got
some applications that have come up in
an unmade track and they use the unmade
track that you can't have
building so how can we
have no footpath at the end onto
fanbridge Road where you're saying that
you can walk to the train station is
that okay now
as I have stated and as the officer of
the committee report states there have
been three appeal decisions within this
area that have
stated that North fanbridge is a
sustainable location including Stevenson
Road even though you'd have to walk down
the road which is unlit
that is a material consideration for
this application I'm not aware of the
sites that you're referring to whether
there is those appeal decisions and
inspectors have stated that it's
sustainable
whether the rows that you're talking
about are 60 miles per hour National
speed limit roads the context of this
site walking down
a quiet residential street
leading to the train station is
completely different to walking over a
mile along an unlit Road
to a bus stop that is only served by
buses every so often compared to a
railway line that served by frequent
services to neighboring villages
um
and we have to have consistency in our
decision making and we are being
consistent with inspectors decisions in
this area by recommending approval for
this application thank you
thank you
just to um support
um what Mr dungote was saying
um I have the appeal decision on book
The Buller Road Site in front of me here
um I'm just at section seven just to
read out the inspector's description of
the area to which he then went on to
allow the appeal uh Buller road is a
single carriageway private road without
segregated footwears it joins the
adopted Highway Network at fanbridge
Road an unlit single carry-free road
with a narrow Footwear on his western
side bambridge road in the vicinity of
Buller Road has several side roads
leading off it with residential
development front of them
thank you chairman thank you
thank you councilor Keys Council
you haven't spoken yet so you get the
next going I know thank you chairman uh
so in terms of this yeah we have to take
into context the fact that other
applications that have been refused were
then approved by the planning inspector
that is that is a really important
consideration in terms of the shared
access
uh we don't all live in houses where we
don't we we have our own driveway I have
a shared access on my house it doesn't
cause any problems for me or my
neighbors in terms of that situation and
it's unlikely that there would be
backfill on this that yeah part of the
design I should imagine is that the
houses will be in line with each other
um into otherwise we're just not going
to pass it when the reserve matters
comes forward
uh in in terms of the the situation you
know this is a residential road which
there are existing houses and this is
the house next house to it it and just
and settlement boundaries is an outdated
outdated policy we're stymied by it
because it's in a local plan at the
moment but it's a constraint it's an
artificial constraint in terms of how
Villages grow and how Villages develop
so we need to think about that this is a
sustainable development it is close to
uh the train station it is close to
other facilities so therefore it's a
sustainable location the the outline I
think with this two houses going to be
there is acceptable so therefore I would
recommend approval of this application
sorry thank you councilor
um just about the footpath I have just
looked on Google Maps
um and there is a footpath leading to
the train station both on fanbridge road
down here obviously wouldn't relate to
this site but they would just have to
walk down here and cross this road so
thank you thank you thank you for that
thanks for Fleming thank you can we just
go back
um to the sort of how sustainable North
fanbridge is I just wanted to point out
a few facts people that aren't familiar
with North vanbridge there are no shops
nothing no Village shop there is a pub
uh some distance from here that they
don't sell snacks or you can't go and
get Provisions there there's no school
so if uh let's just say a young couple
with small children bought one of those
houses there's they would have to drive
to school called Norton or pearly or
even older children they would probably
be driven to a school it's I mean North
fanbridge has constraints in terms of
you know its facilities that there
aren't any facilities it has a train
station that's it used uh you know
commuters use it if they're going into
London and that's it you know you don't
use the train to go to Sainsbury's in
South Woodham Ferris because you you get
to the train station there's you can't
get there so you know anyone who buys in
North Bainbridge has to drive to the
supermarket
sorry not not across the floor
exactly
um yes uh as stated already through
YouTube
um the inspector has inspectors have
stated North fanbridge is a sustainable
location in which occupiers could use
the train station to
meet their day-to-day needs to access
facilities in neighboring Villages
within the council's rural facilities
and settlement survey dated this year
North fanbridge is
um
named as a medium-sized Village in
comparison to wooden Mortimer which is
lower in the scale which has been named
as a Hamlet
um so in comparison to other areas
within Malden North fanbridge is
actually deemed to be more sustainable
and more accessible to other services
and Facilities thank you Jim
yes
um I'm just looking at the date of these
appeal decisions I noticed that they
were before
um the development
um I can't remember the name of it in
north fanbridge
yeah so yeah that it was due to have
local facilities we're supposed to go in
there
so we're supposed to go in there and
actually
um although councilor white and I voted
against it that was
um this committee approved the removal
of the facilities and allowed extra
housing to go in there so I'm just
I'm just a little bit concerned Hannah
that you're quoting these appeal
decisions that are not that relevant to
today
what what is on the ground at the moment
thank you um I believe the most recent
one was 2018
and that's following our local plan and
the late uh well not the latest version
of the mppf but the introduction of the
mppf which was 2012 and we have had
subsequent applications in 2021 2020
2019 that we have determined as a
council and deemed this a sustainable
location
we would not be be seen as being
consistent if we now moved away from
that assessment
of this Village thank you and to be fair
that employment area wasn't necessarily
going to be Village Shops was it and
they weren't there then anyway
oh no I think uh sorry chair there was
due to be a store there quite a big
store from memory
that's correct yeah right
yeah but it wasn't there yet
Council mind uh thank you Chad
um
I said my my problem still is access and
if you go to the Buller Road one and you
look at the application in Buller Road
there was no problem with the access
from there okay it's on an unmade road
but
um you hadn't got a very very small
little Cube to access it and I just
think with the constraints of the axis I
don't think it would be appropriate to
Grant outline permission because we
don't know how the layout is going to
work and I I think with this site we'd
need to have detailed plans to to see if
it was
um a suitable location or not and I
think the problem is if we approve it
we're going to get what we had on the
other big housing estate was while
you've agreed it in principle now you've
got to agree anyway there's nothing you
can do so be able to orientate the
houses whichever way they choose and I
just think there's insufficient
information to determine the application
with the issues on the access that
that's my thoughts and as we say every
application site onto its own and we won
the other appeal with background
development and this is rural in its
nature and it is a clear stop to the
existing development and it is the clear
end of the road and they're saying that
it's on that road there's only a teeny
weeny little portion of it on that road
so for me it's beyond the end of the
road and that's why there's no access
so I don't know how many other sites we
allowed that have got a tiny access like
that that we've lost appeal
um because I I don't I've ever seen a
site with access like that so have we
had many like this with a tiny cubed
axis at the end of the road
I really can only just repeat what was
said before uh this is an outline
application with all matters reserved
uh matters of I mean they have outlined
the the actual site
um the nature of the access will be
subject to any future applications If
This Were to be were to be approved this
is
lines the land that they own and they
don't own anything else to be able to
change the access right the application
site is the application site it's not
about the ownership of the site
so as long as the appropriate notices
are served somebody can make an
application on any piece of land oh no I
know that but when I'm saying is if
the larger rectangle that's there how
would they be able to address the access
issues at the later stage it really is
not a matter for this application and
and to be looking to make a decision on
that basis would almost be ultra virus
so thank you chairman this isn't a thing
then okay through you chairman
um just to confirm as well I've just
measured the plans and the access to the
site is around eight meters in width
which would be sufficient for the
passing of two cars
thank you Tim
the settled up sounded like the
beginnings of a proposal my
recommendation is
it's all second though
in line with the office is recommended
okay that's
proposed Julie seconded by councilor
Keys
um can we vote on that please the
officer's recommendation to approve with
everything is laid out in the report
those in favor
those against
so is that an abstention Council of
Fleming okay have you got that all right
Miss bird
lovely thank you um so yes item five is
approved in line with the officer's
recommendation so at this point we say
good night to councilor Fleming and uh
we'll be pleased to hear you won't be
missing anything if you're not coming
back which I understand you weren't
going to be
oh
nice
thank you so much
thank you
okay moving on so next item uh Second
and last planning application is Spa
Hill Farm Chelmsford road Purley
um we do have a member of the public to
speak it's in fact the applicant and
um we'll we'll have him speaking after
his nuggets presentation sorry falling
over my own teeth thank you chairman
full planning permission is sought for
the construction of a detached out
building to be used as a Farm office and
Welfare facilities the site is located
within the rural area outside of any
defined settlement boundary
this is the site location plan
the application site is located here
within an existing mode open grassland
area
it is located south of the existing
residential dwelling here
um which is associated with Spa Hill
Farm and Spa Hill Farm is located to the
north west of the application site here
where there are a number of large
agricultural buildings
um located around the existing farmyard
and there is also a mobile home located
here
this is the block plan showing the
proposed location of the building
and this is just a a block plan at a
larger scale
these are the proposed elevations of the
building showing that it would have a
domestic appearance
the South elevation also shows that the
proposed entrance to the site would face
um away from the farmyard
um onto the open grassland area to the
South
this is the proposed ground floor of the
building
and this is the proposed first floor
these are photographs of the application
site taken from Chelmsford road
as you can see there are two accesses
um the one to the left is to the
existing farmyard and the one to the
right is to the existing residential
dwelling house and the proposed
development would be served by the
access to the right
these are photographs of the existing
farmyard and agricultural buildings
this is a photograph of the existing
mobile home
and these are photographs facing south
east towards the application site and
the proposed building would be located
behind the dense vegetation there
and this is a photograph showing the
vegetation that would have to some of
which would have to be removed to
facilitate access to the development
um as discussed within the committee
report the remote location of the
development away from the farmyard is
not considered to have been adequately
Justified and is not considered to be
directly linked to the farm as per the
requirements of policy E4
due to its domestic appearance and
sighting within the open grassland area
which is currently free from built form
and the fact that the building has not
been adequately Justified it is
considered to have a harmful impact on
the rural character and appearance of
the area and the proposal is therefore
considered to be contrary to the
policies within the local development
plan and is recommended for refusal
thank you Mr President
it is your turn
so yes come and pick a seat any seat
please make yourself comfortable use the
microphone we're just getting the timer
ready
a little bit as long as you bend it at
the bottom and not the stiff looking fit
in the middle
um we'll start the clock when you begin
to speak so when you're ready
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak we started our farm
26 years ago with five acres we now
employ up to 14 people six of those all
time
part of our business involves
agriculture renewable energy for
electricity generation in the Southeast
most of the other half of our business
in the livestock industry where we
looked after 250 cats and 100 sheep
we were the best Security Council at
Essex Wildlife Church helping to manage
triple SI areas avian flu and TB are as
much of an issue for the lifestyle
industry has covered this to us both
avian Bloom TV is rapidly spreading
through Essex therefore insists upon
stringent biosecurity record keeping and
appropriate start welfare activities
we can no longer work out but obvious an
agricultural house which is eight foot
by five foot staff and business cannot
be expected to Washington meet in our
home
my wife's been very poorly and we cannot
continue as we are risking exposure the
officer appears that we've known our bar
security and employer needs the area in
question is too late for Paddock used
for sheep and cattle adjacent to our
current office in our life the public
already has some two and a half thousand
square feet of light concrete facing
back to 2006 on the road and the small
building was shared
oh the the officer's objections seem to
be Loosely based around policies S1 S8
E4 and D1 Within These policies there is
provision for development of this scale
and designed for an Agricultural
building on agricultural land contrary
to what's been presented to you we
comply with all these policies in the
ldp our employees deserve a decent
environment and no ecological issues
have been raised we have shown a
justifiable need for this modest
low-level building that is in the only
available site as you enter our farm the
building is sympathetic to the three
nearest dwellings which all have Essex
weatherboard cladding this site is
completely shielded from the road by a
hedge 12 foot high 15 foot wide this is
not open Countryside
committee I accept no one likes change
but this is a small building
not affecting I do have to stop here for
two minutes yes
um it's unfortunate about them I won't
make you go through it again
um so members
councilor keys
um can we go back to pictures please
sorry
well where the mobile home is one of my
mom is to the right as we're looking at
that to the right of the mobile home
correct no
yes as in the application site it's
South up it would be better to show you
on the looks
so this is where the mobile home is
located right this is the existing
access to the farmyard right
and
the anybody accessing the Farm office
would have to cross the residential
driveway to the property so which is
owned by the applicant yes well okay
uh can we have a look at the pictures of
the said development or office that it
will be please
glorified stable
I'll take it you said weatherboarding
and sliding your child roof something
like that is it
and there's already a building on the
site the gentleman says and a load of
concrete
Concrete Hard standing not as far as my
site visit showed so that may have
happened after I visited the site but it
was just open grassland
I believe 2006 as mentioned all right
can we go back to the Farmhouse pictures
please
okay yeah no that one you just
oh Farmhouse Farm building
eight people in his house
he said no no I'm thank you madam
challenges
Morgan think about the chairman
um just a little bit of Education I was
under the impression that Agricultural
Development was permitted why in this
particular case is it not being
um yes to you chairman so policy E4 says
that
um develop new agricultural buildings
would be supported subject to a list of
criteria
um and if you bear with me I can name
those criteria
um so the first one is that there is a
justifiable justifiable and functional
need for the building slash activity the
function of the proposed building slash
activity is directly linked and
ancillary to the existing use and the
building slash and the third one the
building slash activity could not be
reasonably located in existing towns
Villages or allocated employment areas
so
this within the um
report it we have assessed the location
of the proposed office so while we may
consider that there is a justifiable
need in terms of welfare facilities or
washing area
um
it has been assessed that there's
already a mobile home within the
existing farmyard the within the and
within close
proximity to the entrance to the site
and this Farm office has not been
Justified to be located in this location
which you would have to walk through the
residential property to access
um
this is the third iteration of this
application the previous applications
have been withdrawn
um and the initial application was
submitted that this building would be
used in conjunction with the dwelling
house
um so
whilst the annotations of the floor
plans have been changed to state that
they would be office and Welfare
facilities initially this building was
to propose to be a workshop and garage
for the dwelling house so although there
may be justification that the office the
agricultural farm would need a building
of this kind it is considered that
it could be better placed in close
proximity to the agriculture the
existing agricultural farmyard
not in this location and we don't feel
that there's been adequate justification
as to why it's been located here
thank you so just to be clear
the reason this doesn't fall within E4
is just because we're they've decided to
locate it
and your or rather officers value
judgment or subjective judgment does to
that
um through your chairman yes and also
that insufficient information has been
submitted in relation to the existing
facilities on the site and why they
wouldn't be adequate so for example if
the mobile home is currently being used
as an area where members of staff are
sitting resting washing
um meetings are taking place why a
replacement of that mobile home with an
adequate building
would not be more reasonable than where
it's currently located so we have
insufficient details about the existing
welfare facilities on the site
to therefore justify why an additional
building in this location would be
acceptable
because the officers do not deny that
that building is going on in on a on
Farmland it's on land that is currently
in agriculture reviews
through 10. oh do you want to say I
don't mind so I don't mind a bit yeah no
just just because I just say to that um
it the policy clearly states that the
council will support the development of
new buildings or activities associated
with agriculture it clearly says that
yep
but then the last word in that bit is
that where
um
and then it lists the three points so
there needs to be the justification so
it's not the fact that
we agree that it's on agricultural land
I mean that's taken for a given as the
starting point the next is the
justification
um use of the word subjective it's an
assessment which officers carry out as
part of their professional judgment
um use of the worst objectives almost
saying that anybody's comment is
subjective this is an informed if you
want to use the word subjective an
informed opinion based on us
um applying our professional
appreciation our understanding having
regard to similar other application and
a consistency and approach and in this
particular application the justification
has not been provided to the standard we
feel is appropriate for us to support
this application thank you chairman
sorry but going back the applicant has
made the point that the reason for the
distance location is because of the and
recent let's be honest uh biodiversity
it has an issues that have grown up with
you know the avian flu Etc which is a
slightly more recent threat than perhaps
has been in the previous in the previous
uh Applications had been made how much
weight was given to those to those
considerations
arguing that the LA and that the
building would be on his Agricultural
and being used by farm animals then its
location away from farm animals and to
foot
for workers to wash away from the
farmyard on a piece of land that's
actually used as part of the farmyard
that doesn't appear to correlate but
again it is stated that although it
might be justifiable that workers need
to wash in their welfare facilities it's
the location of it away from the farm
yard that's not reasonable and it's not
directly linked to the farmyard is the
consideration that's been made workers
would have to cross the residential
driveway
um
to use these facilities
and yeah
it's not justified in our opinion I'm
just gonna have to come back on that
that's a complete to my mind well let's
let's be let's be polite but if you have
facilities that are required to be
carried out professionally on a
particular site the fact that those have
to be for for various reasons away from
where perhaps the actual activity is
going does not mean to say that they're
no longer part of that site I I don't I
just don't see them don't get the point
the officers are trying to make I really
don't
foreign
ification why the why the building could
not be cited on the farm itself where
there is an existing mobile home no
justification for that has been has been
submitted and officers have the benefit
of the history of this site or the
history of a number of applications uh
come in here
um or which rather is manifested in
terms of the application in front of you
that just does not follow now we're not
saying that
but explicitly saying that there's any
particular reasoning why there may have
been different applications submitted
beforehand but this is the third
iteration which
um provides an application which wasn't
submitted in the first place if the need
was required for quite some time now
if that was backed up with the fact of
discount in any particular site on the
farm itself
as to why the building could not be
found there then that's something we
would take into consideration but that
has not been demonstrated there's not
been that sort of sequential test if you
want to put it in that sort of way thank
you chairman
cancer cell
are you madam chairman uh
I can I can see the need for this at
this particular farm and I can
understand the the applicant coming
forward with this particular thing
however I I like the officers I really
do not understand why they haven't cited
it at the farm yard and why they're
putting it in this particular Paddock
the other strange thing is that the
access to this building is around the
other side it's not even the access
isn't even Facing The Farmhouse so to
get into the building you've got to go
all the way around it yeah so I could
understand it a bit more or if the
access was on to the building was on the
other side of the building now we're
talking about
um you know bird flu and and yeah you
thought a mouse might happen again yeah
in terms of that what tends to happen is
they put a lot of restrictions around
the farm farm yard and they put the
things that you've got to walk through
right by the farm yard
so someone would have to come through to
a domestic property then get washed and
again that doesn't make any sense to me
so I I can definitely see the need for
this and I can understand that the
landowner wants to do this but I really
can't understand why they want to do it
in that particular location and that's
my concern is that there's there's to me
there's lots of other space that this
could be done on where there is hard
standing where there are existing build
agricultural buildings and we tend to
pass agricultural buildings on uh
pasture land when it's a barn that's
used for and there aren't any of the
barns there or is it for particular
agricultural facilities again this
doesn't fit that
um so yeah I I I I I I'm into Minds
obviously
as a domestic dwelling no council White
um
sorry my eyes didn't be watering for
some reason I don't know why
um I think I can see exactly why they've
got the um we're farmers
um and we used to have a lot of cattle
uh we don't now I've only got horses now
but we used to love cattle east of a
mixed farm and
um what we did
um or one of the other Farms that we had
we specifically it was to end BSE first
came around and nobody knew what was
actually
um bringing on the BSE and we've since
found out that it was actually
contaminated to feed and we were given
the choice at the time of either feeding
um an actual product or a chemical we
chose the natural additive naturality
was grown-up sheep brain anyway sorry
I'm getting away from the subject so
from there and all these other diseases
we've had
um we actually had to put the exclusion
zones and or not the farm in Mall
District another Farm we had to actually
build a welfare building and we put it
so it was near to the residential house
because we wanted to make sure that the
work we're going to get it out didn't go
anywhere near the farm yard and didn't
go anywhere near the animals and we
could be certain that they would because
they will wash us are entirely effective
um so that worked for us to practicality
now I don't know if that's why this
applicant has done that but actually to
me it makes perfect sense why he's put
it there
um and
I as far as where as well I think the
applicant if I'm correct if I can see
the blue line I think my own all the
land in front
of the building do they have that pink
bit I think that's all in the
application the same ownership on the
right hand side isn't it yes uh yeah so
I mean the for me they could have put
another axis in there would have been a
reason there must have been a reason why
they they went round
um in front of the house and I could
only think it's because of biosecurity
and you can tell easily from the house
when the work will clock in what the
work will clock out and when they're
going for their lunch
um so for me that makes absolute perfect
sense
um that's um I've still got to sell that
one
oh sorry cancel
I I understand everything that uh
councilor white has just said however
this building is 22 meters away from the
existing Farmhouse so it's not even
close to the existing farmhouse
so yet yes that would be the case if it
was five meters or so from the existing
front but it's fat that it's 22 meters
away from the existing Farmhouse so it's
not even close to that
so again that makes it questionable in
terms of its location
I'm just kind of on the line again thank
you chairman that um again this
application has not presented any
particular justification
um I am just mindful of justification
being provided uh for the applicant but
this has not been enshrined within the
application itself now it may well be
that an argument could be made but this
argument hasn't been demonstrated it
must have been submitted within this
application for us to support it hence
the position of where we are with this
application thank you chairman
foreign
the location of this unit that is giving
officers difficulty
Mr Johnson that's cool thank you
chairman um well I'm not sure about it's
just giving officers difficulties not
because of our applying the word of the
plan so this isn't anything personal in
that sense so I just need to just make
that quite clear
um
you know there is a presumption against
buildings in the countryside unless it's
for specific purposes and those purposes
must be justified that's why we must
apply the most rigorous of tests in when
we are considering these and if those
tests are passed then we and obviously
other particular principles are are
accepted then we would support the
application we do support applications
where they are sufficiently Justified as
an appropriate design in front of us
um and we feel that it's in line with
the with the principles within the local
plan
that's just not the case from officer's
point of view here
thank you chairman so it's all about the
evidence or not thank you
[Music]
Council
uh so therefore could we defer the
application and ask for the applicant to
come forward with further Evidence
is an idea uh yeah and in terms of
whether they could look at whether this
could be cited Elsewhere on the site is
that something that we could we could
put forward as as a as a a
recommendation rather than just refusing
it elsewhere becomes a new applications
with presumably evidence well thank you
Jim I mean I'd be concerned about just
deferring this for some more applic I
mean
that you know effectively they'd be
making a new application if it's of very
similar kind but issues would have been
noted within refusals just for example
if this application were to be refused
by members in the way officers have
recommended
um within that may be the basis from
which they can go back and reconsider
what needs to be done provide more
justification these are the things that
through an application that they can
have a discussion with officers yeah
um that's just not the case here
but it's definitely not one for deferral
to get a bit more information
which would then may need to be subject
to further consultation and things of
that nature
thank you chairman thank you
I was just going to add um that
obviously if this if it was relocated
that would amend the red line and then
it would be a new application yeah thank
you thank you councilor sidelman it gets
it out to the members of the public why
we do and don't do what we do that's why
we do things in committee
um
councilman can I just really just say
that I've listened to what officers have
said I fully understand the point
they're trying to make but I really
don't think that I agree with the way
that I have applied uh policy E4 and
therefore I propose that this
application be accepted citing policy E4
sorry I'm just checking up and reason
for refusal here just don't want to miss
anything up
okay have you got anything to add on S1
S8 or D one Council well actually
funnily enough uh going back to the
previous application with regards to as
well I know that officers say that the
in fact does comply with the um uh S1 in
in terms of the S8
um
allowances
so we can add up S1 as well
sorry it's one where I said sorry could
someone talk us through S1 and S8 please
s policy S8
lists a number of accepted development
within the rural area which includes
Agricultural and Forestry development in
accordance with policy E4 so
if you're saying that it's acceptable in
relation to E4 then you're saying it's
except we're in relation to S8
yep
D1 is design and S1 is sustainability
difficult because of this that because
of people very small world yes
yes you've done
to be fair you don't sound quite as good
as you did however
um but yes well that satisfies a
covering of the reasons for a refusal
thank you councilor Morgan uh those uh
we'd have to delegate conditions to the
officers which we can do in consultation
with me and well Council might as well
remember
and okay can we have a shot
slowly
if the proposal been put forward sorry
um yes I think it was
as long as your secondary is prepared to
accept your yeah
okay so can we have a show of hands
infography proposal to approve councilor
Morgan okay those against
and council's little abstaining okay
fair enough
so that being said yes we have this
application is proposed the conditions
will be delegated to officers
um the next item on the agenda is item
seven any items of business the chairman
decides are Urgent you'll be delighted
to hear there are none so thank you to
officers members members of the public
um thank you for your contributions and
I closed the meeting at 8 35.